il est vrai que le temps ça prend de la
grèce de pommes salaires des gens
voulaient que l'avion ne soit fait que
de 15 capables et que en fait se fasse
forme pratiquement cochon ça donne dix à
douze le dessus et que le forum les
responsab serions que dans le fond c'est
à partir de ce seulement kraton mais ça
ne veut pas ça veut dire que ces sommes
donc en principe légère ajoute ne pas
relâcher quand on veut la légion fait
rage tout poulet haché ou du veau haché
ce qui est fortement déconseillé célèbre
fâché parce que ça ça devient trop dur
le boeuf
ça fait pas du bon temps avec titoff
humain fait que moi je suis chanceuse
j'ai acheté la gosse h l'album je me
casse pas le propos je fais ça avec mes
sketches annexe à peine carroll
quelle période de l'année les grattons
un peu précis parce qu'on avait une
immense congélateur comme toute famille
notre monde fait que maintenant elle
allait à la salaison
c'était plus que de boucherie les
salaires et acheter ce genre ce moment
le couple du flanc de porc parce que
c'est mieux de le hsv même que ma mère
faisait quand j'étais petit
quant à face aux dictateurs pas ta
passion de la cuisine advient-il ta main
tremble ou l'autre chez nous on mange
simplement mais on mangeait du team
allemand était capable d'aller chercher
les aliments qu'elle ne leur ont mangé
par saison
[Musique]
c'est ce pas
bon
[Musique]
on
laurens